no i i stayed up till 7 30 a.m every
night
and who would have thought who would
have thought that would cause me to feel
like absolute garbage right that's crazy
isn't that crazy yeah that works yeah i
feel like i got hit by a bus
in the best way possible it's a great
thing you have that feel right now
because we actually got gary on the ship
who gary v okay now that you feel like
you've been hit by a bus
yeah wait wait can we play that clip i
think this maybe will help
bring me back to life yeah yeah i would
say gary vee
would say you're in the perfect mindset
right now to be successful
exactly you've just been hit by a bus
[Laughter]
now we'll solve a rubik's cube spock
santa says hold on pause it
spock sent us this clip yesterday and i
think it's just absolutely perfect it's
the perfect sequel
did you see it no oh you're gonna love
this dude
you're gonna love this let's go 25
and i'm like man i really been you're
like bro i'd rip both my legs off and
arms to be 25
on some real [ __ ] i'd give up everything
i have to be 25 just to play again
25 is a baby that's how i feel about
going back to 16 sometimes man like i
hate it but [ __ ] growing up sucks on
songs
you want to go back to be 20 to be 25
but
have no arms and no legs
why is it gotta be so violent
i'd rip both my arms and legs like that
it's so
[ __ ] crappy dude that's such a
crazy ass response
i would rip my own arm off you
understand
[Applause]
and then you gotta rip the other one off
somehow with only one arm
and then how are you going to get your
feet up
so they you get that one off
[Applause]
and so now they're both spraying blood
now you have to eat your own legs off
but once you do at least you'll be 25.
what do you do like hang over a building
like do you ask your friends like now
you're bleeding from the arms
screaming your friends are freaking out
and you're like put cinder blocks on my
legs
hang me over the building hang it
just do it i want to be 25 again or is
it no it's the inverse i got to hang
your legs over a building and then put
cinder blocks here so you lose all the
circulation
yeah and then they can just detach and
then you just
fall with no limbs
on top of a building you're just rolling
around
bleeding from every hole and you just
start getting younger as you're bleeding
out
yes yes
i had to be young again
[Laughter]
if you change your relationship with it
yo who is it who is even like what
what situation even is this like where
are they what who is this
guy
bro y'all just gotta change your
relationship with it
you know i'm thinking about
[ __ ] boy garyvee like if garyvee and
taylor holder ran into each other
garyvee just he's got a crop top t-shirt
with his last name tattooed under his
belly button b
bro i ripped my [ __ ] arms and legs
off to be 25 again
yep that's just if you change your
relationship with it
[Laughter]
oh god no cap i literally stabbed my mom
in her eyes to be 25 again bro
[Laughter]
on god i would straight up put a a set
of billiard balls down my dad's throat
to be 25 again
straight up i feed a nine-year-old a bag
of nails
[Laughter]
you guys into crypto by the way
god i feed a dog a bag of nails and
bolts to be 25 again
no cap
i straight ripped my toenails out bro to
be 25 again
taylor's like what
with all the sway boys are all like
disgusting look at each other like
[ __ ] is wrong with this dude right boys
they're just
no cab did i twist out my balls and cut
them off
to be your age you know what i'm saying
if you just change your relationship
with it
you know the best part is this is his
actual account
i feel like his editor like does this on
purpose oh definitely
he's like this is a gold clip right she
finds the most absurd clips
what's the top top comment on this
gary i'm 25. i still have my arms and my
legs what do i do
that's a good question man rip them off
rip them off rip them off dog
i'm i'm just i'm dead man i'm 20 though
i feel old
mistake he just said mistake
what that thought was wrong
oh damn gary
[Laughter]
sorry i'm just still stuck on his
violent
uh you know just his violent
um compromises he'd be young again oh
yeah
gary's you don't want to be with gary
i think gary v is probably the most
terrifying person to be with like if
you found like a magic lamp with a genie
in it mm-hmm
you don't know what horrible [ __ ] he
would be willing to do for like three
wishes yeah yeah
yeah the genie's like kill him and i'll
give you four wishes he's gonna
[ __ ] he won't even blink yeah he will
literally murder you he's demented
yeah he is demented you know but he he'd
be the worst person ever to
to trip with like to take shrooms or oh
god
could you imagine how bad of a trip
you'd have like dude
you ever think about drowning you're
like what
no this is what it would be like lean
back
waterboards waterboarding yeah
[Laughter]
i'll waterboard you then you waterboard
me
or yeah he he man he just be at
like he'd be asking you things
probably weird philosophical questions
like
yo you know that you you know that
philosophical thing like would you kill
one person to save a hundred
yeah would you stab five people to save
200
i don't what you got to stab five people
what did they do it doesn't matter
you just gotta stab them like hard could
you do that
could you commit murder could you
could you get murdered think about
getting murdered
yeah think about that one second would
you get murdered to save a hundred
people you just
you're just slowly going to the dark
place yeah
going to this awful hole you ever
thought about being buried alive
no i know you want to be don't take me
back
you ever thought about what your
grandma's last words were before she
died
you ever think about ripping off your
grandma's arms
[Laughter]
to bring her back would you rip off your
arms and legs to bring your grandma back
what
man i'm just sorry i'm just still
thinking about the genie situation as
well
like you know typically where do you
find a magic lamp it's usually in some
hidden cave right with a bunch of
treasure and [ __ ] yeah i feel like this
dude pin you down and just stuff your
mouth full of gold coins until you
suffocated
yeah you just [ __ ] just i'm sorry bro
i need it though i need that fourth wish